[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
eigentlich ist das Weihnachtsgeschäft
bei Galeria karstadtkaufhof gut gelaufen
und trotzdem muss die Kaufhauskette
jetzt wieder einmal Insolvenz anmelden
was aktuell vor allem an ihrem
vermeintlichen Retter liegt dem
österreichischen Immobilien Tycoon Rene
Benko das dessen pleiteimperium auf
tönenden Füßen stand verursacht an
ziemlich vielen Standorten in Österreich
und Deutschland Probleme möglicherweise
auch Investitionsruinen von denen kein
Mensch weiß ob und wann sie zu Ende
gebaut werden für die Galeria
Warenhäuser kommt noch oben drauf dass
an ihren vermiet benkos signargruppe
auffällig hohe Mieten zahlen mussten
damit soll künftig aber Schluss sein
sagt der Insolvenzverwalter wie er jetzt
versucht zu retten was zu retten ist
beschreibt Sven
ren vorne glänzt die Fassade in der
Wintersonne hinten hat die Signa Holding
von Rene Benko Spuren hinterlassen jeden
Tag blicken die verbliebenen 250
Mitarbeiter dieser Karstadtfiliale in
Hamburg eine Bauruine der siegnergruppe
gegenüber die Insolvenz war also jeden
Tag greifbar seit heute ist sie zum
dritten Mal da stand heute haben wir 92
Filialen die werden wir stand heute
weiterbetreiben aber wie gesagt die
vermittungsgespräche muss noch laufen
und dann muss wir die Konsequenzen
ziehen seit heute Vormittag heißt es
also wieder Insolvenzverfahren
eingereicht am Amtsgericht in Essen drei
große Aufgaben haben Insolvenzverwalter
und Geschäftsleitung jetzt für die
Häuser müssen die Mieten runter das das
Unternehmen braucht dringend neues Geld
also einen Investor und es braucht neue
Ideen für neue Kunden das heißt
allerdings nicht dass alle Warenhäuser
erhalten bleiben immerhin die Löhne der
Mitarbeiter sind erstmal gesichert wir
haben jetzt den
insolvenzgeldzeitraum bis Ende März die
Agentur hat hat mitgeteilt dass
Insolvenzgeld auch in diesem Verfahren
gezahlt werden wird mit Rene Benko kam
nicht der erhoffte Wandel sondern wurde
alles komplizierter so muss der
Insolvenzverwalter über Mietsenkungen
mit vielen verschiedenen Unterfirmen
verhandeln teilweise auch mit deren
Insolvenzverwaltern dabei war immer klar
ohne Kulturwandel in den Warenhäusern
wird es schwierig die älteren kommen
garantiert weil die haben Lust auf
Beratungen das vor Ort anfassen die
jüngeren Menschen kann ich erreichen
über ein multichannel Handel oder über
ein Hybriden online handandel indem ich
die Ware die ich ja vor Ort habe
eigentlich verfügbar mache dass sie sich
jemand abholen kommt Vorort in der
Hamburger City heißt nur noch bei einem
Haus eine Galeria und eine kstad
sportfiliale mussten bereits schließen
für die verbliebenen Mitarbeiter des
geöffneten Traditionshauses eine stäte
Erinnerung wie es eben auch enden
kann da fragen wir noch nach bei unserem
Wirtschaftsfachmann Frank betmann das
ist ja für Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof nun
schon die dritte Insolvenz was ist denn
diesmal anders als bei den vorherigen na
die ersten beiden Insolvenzen hatten das
Ziel in einer für die Warenhausgruppe
kritischen Situation die Geschäfte
weiterzuführen eine
schutzschirmininsolvenz bei der das
Management umstrukturiert hat und der
Insolvenzverwalter versuchte Lieferanten
und anderen Gläubigern Zugeständnisse
abzuringen damit es weitergehen kann
jetzt handelt es sich um eine
Regelinsolvenz bei dem der
Insolvenzverwalter einerseits alles in
Frage stellt auch die Fortführung der
Geschäfte und andererseits versucht
mögliche Käufer für Galeria zu finden
dabei ist eine Zers lagung der
Warenhauskette denkbar wahrscheinlich
sogar glaubt man den Handelsexperten
dann besteht wenn überhaupt nur noch an
den profitablen Filialen Interesse da
reden wir von höchstens 50 bis 60
Warenhäusern eher weniger die übrigen
Filialen stünden dann vor dem Aus das
führt natürlich zu der bankenfage was
das dann für die Beschäftigten heißt ja
deren Zukunft ist ungewisser und
unsicherer denn je muss man leider sagen
geht es für einen selbst bei Galeria
weiter oder wird man arbeitslos wenn es
überhaupt einen Trost gibt dann den dass
im Einzelhandel Fachkräfte gesucht
werden und sicherlich viele der
Mitarbeiter die nun ihren Job verlieren
könnten gute Chancen haben woanders
wieder unterzukommen danke schön nach
Frankfurt gerne bei den bauernprotesten
dieser Tage müssen es in den einzelnen
Städten ja gar nicht so viele Personen
sein die sich beteiligen die Straße des
17 Juni in Berlin die kriegt man schon
mit einigen hundert Traktoren dch
andere Berufsgruppen haben es da
schwerer auf Ihre Belange aufmerksam zu
machen entweder muss man sehr viel mehr
Fußvolk auf die Straße bringen oder
spürbar streiken Ärzte und Ärztinnen mit
eigener Praxis tun das eher selten aber
diesmal gab es einen bundesweiten Aufruf
der Verbände zwischen den Jahren die
Praxen geschlossen zu halten der Protest
zielt vor allem auf die bisher geltenden
budgetregeln heute gab es dazu ein
Treffen mit Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach britter spiermann erklärt
worum es
geht Kardiologe Norbert zmetter hat es
satt zu viel Bürokratie zu wenig Zeit
für Patienten und dann noch die
buüdgettierung ein Honorar das pro
Quartal gedeckelt ist versorgen
niedergelassene Ärzte darüber hinaus
Patienten wird das nicht vergütet die
Folge weniger Termine lange Wartezeiten
für die Patienten kein Beruf hat es gern
wenn eine Leistung erbringt s er kriegt
sie nicht bezahlt und budgtierung ist
schlichtweg natürlich auch wieder was
die Leistungsbereitschaft betrifft
hemmend wenn eben eine gewisse Leistung
nicht mehr vergütet wird dann wird sie
eventuell nicht mehr erbracht wenn ich
Termine deswegen nicht mehr zur
Verfügung stellen kann weil eben das
Geld nicht da ist dann fehlt's halt auch
an der Versorgung Krisentreffen der
Ärztevertreter am Nachmittag mit
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach den
Hausärzten zumindest will er nun
Entgegenkommen ihre honorarobergrenzen
sollen weg en zudem soll ein neues
Vergütungssystem her indem die Praxen
die besonders bedeutsam sind für die
Versorgung die viele Patienten versorgen
die Hausbesuche machen die sozusagen die
versorgerpraxen sind die werden eine
poschale bekommen einfach für die
Vorhaltung dieser Leistung die Hausärzte
zufrieden Lauterbach will ihre Praxen
entökonomisieren Ihnen wieder mehr
Freiraum für die medizinische Behandlung
geben wenn die niedergelassenen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mehr Zeit
hätten für die wirklich kranken
Patienten wenn nicht so viel Zeit
verloren ginge für Bürokratie und für
also Patienten die nur einbestellt
werden um damit das Honorar generieren
zu können volle Unterstützung von
unserer Seite für die Maßnahmen es muss
aber ein Prozess sein ein erster Schritt
ein Schritt der schnell erfolgt in der
konkreten Umsetzung und der durch
weitere solche Treffen begleitet wird
gemeinsam hatten im Dezember Haus und
Fachärzte für ein Ende der
honorardeckelung gestreigt ihre Praxen
geschlossen heute gehen die Fachärzte
leer aus der wchubund droht erneut mit
Streik wir haben ja die entbudgettierung
der fachärzlichen Leistungen gefordert
da hat sich der Minister nicht bewegt er
sagt zwar es werde dran gearbeitet aber
wir brauchen konkrete Zusagen und
solange wir die konkreten Zusagen nicht
haben müssen wir weiter im
protestmodusfahren die Kassen sie sind
gegen eine entbudgettierung bei Haus und
bei Fachärzten
wir können davon ausgehen dass wenn sich
die Honorierung der Ärzte nennenswert
steigern würde dass das am Ende auch
steigende krankenkassenbeiträg bedeuten
würde denn irgendjemand muss es bezahlen
Facharzt smag wird von den angekündigten
Änderungen nichts haben ein
dreistelliger Millionenbetrag ist der
neuen hausarztvergütung vorbehalten sein
Honorar bleibt weiterhin
gedeckelt auf ihrer Nahostreise setzt
Außenministerin berbur neben der
klassischen rechtsdiplomatie auch auf
symbolische Besuche an neuralgischen
Orten etwa im Westjordanland wo sie mit
Palästinensern über deren Probleme mit
radikalen israelischen Siedlern sprach
das soll natürlich Signale senden an
beide Seiten Sowi heute ihr Besuch in
Raffa dort liegt der einzige
Grenzübergang zwischen dem Gazastreifen
und Ägypten hier werden humanitäre
Hilfslieferungen durchgeschickt und auch
wer Gaza verlassen will kommt hier durch
oder eben auch nicht andreas küners hat
den Auftritt der Ministerin dort
beobachtet dass sich bitte jeder eine
splitterschutzweste und einen Helm zu
nehmen hat am Mittag auf dem Flughafen
Kairo ist der erste unwirkliche Moment
dieser Mission gepanzert reist die
deutsche ministerdelegation an die
Grenze zum Gazastreifen hinter der es
für 1,9 Millionen Menschen keinen Schutz
gibt
nirgendwo des berbockflugs sind
Isomatten Decken Kinderschlafsäcke und
Feldbetten 10 Tonnen das ist im
Vergleich zum Bedarf eine winzige Menge
aber vielleicht wird es einigen Menschen
helfen ihre Verteilung soll eine
norwegische Hilfsorganisation übernehmen
der das Auswärtige Amt vertraut damit
sie nicht in die Hände der Hamas fallen
auf dem Weg nach rafach kommt bbox
Kolonne an den Lastwagen vorbei
hunderten tausenden die darauf warten
kontrolliert zu werden hier steht Essen
und Trinken dass Familien zum Überleben
bräuchten Narkosemittel um das Ärzte
Flehen um operieren zu können die Grenze
zu Gaza ist die Grenze des
Erträglichen wir dürfen ab und zu ein
paar Kinder oder Frauen evakuieren
natürlich ausschließlich Zivilisten sie
haben meistens gebrochene Knochen oder
amputierte Gliedmaßen oder
raketensplitter im
Körper rafach ist der einzige Weg nach
Gaza der nicht über Israel führt berbock
fordert die israelische Regierung auf
noch mehr ihrer Übergänge zu öffnen und
mehr humanitäre Feuerpausen zu befehlen
noch gestern hatte die deutsche
Außenministerin in Tel Aviv Angehörige
der hamasgeiseln getroffen hatte Israel
Solidarität und Hilfe versprochen jetzt
steht sie in der anderen Welt ich weiß
auch dass in deinem Land viele unsere
unumstößliche
is nur schwer nachvollziehen können am
Morgen streitet sich berbock in Kairo
mit Außenminister schukri der Ägypter
wirft Israel vor mit Absicht Zivilisten
auch Journalisten zu töten berbock sagt
den Vorsatz weise ich
zurück es ist unerträglich die ganze
internationale Gemeinschaft steht da wie
gefesselt während die größtesiedlung der
Palästinenser erfolgt
iseminter des internationalen Rechts
verteidigen können jeder von uns würde
das tun wenn uns ein 7 Oktober
wiederfahren wäre am Abend reist die
deutsche Außenministerin weiter in den
Libanon die gerade alle deutschen zur
Ausreise aufgefordert hat im Libanon
droht der Ausbruch des nächsten Krieges
dort leben 6 Millionen Menschen die
können nicht
weg nicht n die deutsche Außenministerin
ist auf t auch ihr US-amerikanischer
Amtskollege blinken er war heute in Tel
Aviv Luk weallport ist dort unser
Reporter L mit welcher Botschaft kam
blinken denn nach
Israel keine wirklich neue Botschaft
vielleicht eine eindringlichere als bei
den drei Reisen zuvor er hat
eindringlich an seine israelischen
Partner noch einmal appelliert dringend
alles zu unternehmen um weitere
Zivilopfer in Gaza zu vermeiden dann hat
er auch darum gebeten mehr zu tun von
israelischer Seite um die humanitäre die
dringend benötigte humanitäre Hilfe in
Gaza verstärkt
hereinzulassen er hat sich besorgt
geäußert über eine mögliche Ausweitung
des Konflikts das betrifft insbesondere
die heftigen Kämpfe der letzten Tage an
der Nordgrenze also der Grenze Israel
zum Libanon und dann hat er auch eine
Frage in Richtung Zukunft geworfen wie
soll es denn weitergehen wenn dieser
Krieg einmal endet nämlich die zwei
Staaten lös s davon will aber zumindest
die Rechtsextremen Koalitionspartner
hier in der Regierung Netanyahu nichts
wissen blinken hat betont dass er
durchaus weiterhin an der Seite israel
steht was das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung anbelangt nämlich
israel habe das Recht die hammas
auszuschalten habe das Recht die
Terrorangriffe die das Land am 7 Oktober
erleiten musste nicht noch einmal zu
erfahren und alles Militärische dafür zu
unternehmen aber er hat auch appelliert
daran es könne langfristig nur eine
Lösung mit den Palästinensern geben in
Richtung einer Zweistaatenlösung also
einen pfaht für einen palästinensischen
Staat müsse man aufweisen allzu viel
Nachdruck war da nicht dahinter es ist
wie gesagt die vierte Reise Blinkens und
die Ergebnisse sind alles in allem doch
eher mager danke schön nach Tel Aviv und
mit den Nachrichten gehen wir jetzt
erstmal zurück nach Deutschland Heinz
wie schon das Arbeitsgericht Frankfurt
gestern hat heute auch das
Landesarbeitsgericht Hessen den gdlstik
nicht per Eilverfahren untersagt die GDL
hatte im Tarifstreit mit der Bahn ihre
Mitglieder zur Arbeitsniederlegung
aufgerufen ab heute 18 Uhr bei DB Cargo
und im Personenverkehr ab Mittwoch 2 Uhr
bis Freitag 18 Uhr die Bahn spricht von
massiven Beeinträchtigungen in ihrem
fernregional und S-Bahnverkehr und hat
für morgen einen Notfahrplan mit einem
begrenzten zugangeb Boot
eingesetzt Bundespräsident Steinmeier
hat angesichts der wachsenden
Aggressivität in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung zu Mäßigung und
Gewaltfreiheit aufgerufen Wut sei kein
guter Ratgeber in der Demokratie sagte
Steinmeier beim Neujahrsempfang im
Schloss belvü in Berlin dort waren heute
rund 150 Vertreter des öffentlichen
Lebens und 60 ehrenamtlich engagierte
Bürger
eingeladen die Grünen haben sich mit
einer Vorstandsklausur auf dieses Jahr
mit der Europawahl und drei
Landtagswahlen eingestimmt unter anderem
wird ein höherer Mindestlohn gefordert
die letzte Anhebung sei größtenteils
durch die Inflation aufgezierrt worden
sagt die grünenchefin lang außerdem will
die Partei eine schnelle Entscheidung
über Lieferungen von
taurusmarschflugkörpern an die
Ukraine neuer Premierminister
Frankreichs wird der bisherige
Bildungsminister Gabriel Atal er gilt
als enger Vertrauter von Präsident
macron Atal übernimmt das Amt von der
gestern zurückgetretenen Elisabeth born
er ist 34 Jahre alt und wird damit zum
jüngsten Premierminister des Landes der
Wechsel gilt als Schachzug macrons der
seine Regierung vor der Europawahl im
Juni neuen Schwung bringen
soll
US-Verteidigungsminister Asten wird
wegen Prostatakrebs im Krankenhaus
behandelt seine heil Aussichten sein
hervorragend teilte das zuständige
Klinikum mit die tagelange Ungewissheit
über die Art der Erkrankung des
Verteidigungsministers hatte scharfe
Kritik der oppositionellen Republikaner
ausgelöst
sten hatte sich am Wochenende für die
Informationspolitik
entschuldigt er wird seit dem
Neujahrstag im Krankenhaus behandelt
nachdem es zu Komplikationen kam die
nach seiner prosterter Operation kurz
vor Weihnachten aufgetreten
waren das hier das will kein Fluggast je
zu sehen bekommen ein klaffendes Loch
der Kabinenwand mit ungewollter
Frischluftzufuhr in 5000 m Höhe ein
Albtraum für die Passagiere des Alaska
Airline flugs bei deren Flug das letzten
Freitag passiert ist und ein Albtraum
für den US-Hersteller Boeing der diesen
Flugzeugtyp
herstellt möglicherweise aber auch noch
ein Albtraum für andere Airlines nicht z
letzt für die deutsche lufthanser die
gerade erst Boeings vom Typ 737 MAX für
ihre Flotte bestellt hat und sich
natürlich fragen muss wie vielen ihrer
Kunden mullmich wird wenn sie in diese
Flieger einsteigen
sollen das ist eine Frage die sich
natürlich auch für die Boeing in den USA
stellt und die außerdem auch die
aktuellen Untersuchungen des fallsdien
es dort jetzt immer noch aufzuklären
gibt begleiten Elma
berichtet
von Bob sauer gab es nie wirklich
spektakuläres bis er abends mit der
Taschenlampe etwas
entdeckte im Lichtstrahl sah ich etwas
glänzend weißes unter den
Bäumen Bob übrigens Lehrer von Beruf
traute seinen Augen
nicht mein Herz schlug schneller ich
dachte oh Gott das suchen Sie doch schon
das ganze Wochenende der Fund in Bobs
Garten in Portland Oregon könnte
entscheidend dazu beitragen das nie
wieder passiert was selbst langjährige
Experten der Flugsicherheitsbehörde
sprachlos machte für ihre Chefin grund
genug rückhaltlose Aufklärung zu
versprechen wir werden nicht zögern die
Untersuchung auf die gesamte Flotte
auszudehnen das haben wir auch früher
schon gemacht und tun das wieder wenn
wir ein systemisches Problem
sehen denn der Vorfall am Freitag hätte
für 180 Menschen den Tod bedeuten können
wenn das Flugzeug schon die Reisehöhe
erreicht hätte die Passagiere ahnten
nicht dass sie in einer Maschine saßen
bei der schon früher Warnleuchten einen
möglichen Druckabfall angezeigt
hat ich schlief gerade dann sackte alles
ab das war keine Turbulenz die Masken
fielen raus und das war der Moment an
dem ich dann fast ausgeflippt
bin was zunächst als Einzelfall bei
Alaska Airlines aussah ist wohl doch ein
größeres Problem die Techniker
entdeckten auch bei United Airlines lose
Schrauben an den nottüren die von innen
als normale Kabinenwand verkleidet sind
Schlamperei bei der Herstellung der
Boeing 737 MAX die Aufmerksamkeit
konzentriert sich nun auf den Zulieferer
Spirit der den Rumpf der Maschinen
fertigt aufgrund früherer Probleme mit
der 737 MAX stand die Produktion lange
still gute Mitarbeiter verließen Spirit
als wieder neue Flugzeuge bestellt
wurden hatten die Hersteller nach der
pandemiepreme gute neue Leute zu
finden diese Produktion lässt Null
Spielraum für Fehler es wäre die Aufgabe
des Managements gewesen die neuen
Mitarbeiter anzulernen um wieder mehr
Flugzeuge herzustellen sie zu trainieren
sicherzustellen dass Sie Ihre Aufgabe
komplett erledigen und das hat offenbar
nicht
stattgefunden nun dürfen 200 Flugzeuge
dieses Typs vorerst nicht starten Boeing
muss mit Schadensersatzforderungen
rechnen geschätzt 5 Millionen Dollar pro
Tag
das geld ist nicht das Entscheidende es
geht um den Schaden für den Ruf es sieht
so aus als seinen die Schwierigkeiten
bei den Zulieferern und bei Boeing schon
so lange vorhanden dass da noch mehr
kommen
könnte dass das gleiche nicht noch mal
geschieht dafür will die
Flugsicherheitsbehörde Sorgen denn beim
nächsten Vorfall könnte es viel
schlimmer
ausgehen die Piloten der Alaska Airlines
haben jedenfalls mit rein menschlich
Intelligenz das einzig Richtige getan so
schnell wie möglich die Passagiere
zurück zum Boden zu bringen aber
natürlich spielt auch künstliche
Intelligenz KI im Luftverkehr und beim
Flugzeugbau längst eine große Rolle KI
ist überall und in aller Munde und ist
aktuell auch bei der großen Technikmesse
CES in Las Vegas das dominante Thema
unser Reporter Benjamin daniel hat sich
dort auf jene künstlich intelligenten
Dinge gestürzt die alltagstauglich sind
z.B KI zur
eherettung dieses Kissen hilft Streit
mit ihrer Partnerin oder Ihrem Partner
zu vermeiden das versprechen die
Entwickler jenen die nachts
Schnarchen wenn man nicht schnarcht ist
das ein ganz normales Kissen und wenn
man schnarcht dann bläst es sich so auf
dass sich der Kopf gerade so weit dreht
dass man nicht mehr schnet und sie
nennen es den
eheretter bei fast jedem Produkt das auf
der CIS gezeigt wird spielt KI eine
Rolle diese Drohne beispielsweise
transportiert Laborproben und
Medikamente sie ist leise schnell
klimaschonend und kann zum B und
Entladen an Fensterbänken andocken alles
voll automatisiert die KI hilft auch
wenn es Probleme am Himmel
gibt wenn Objekte auf einmal aufköten
Fallschirmspringer ein Helikopter ein
Flugzeug parakleider irgendwas was leise
ist was vielleicht kein transponter dran
hat dann müssen wir das auch wiederum
mit Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz
erkennen können auch aus der Autobranche
ist KI nicht mehr wegzudenken BMW
demonstriert in diesem Jahr auf der CES
unter anderem das Potenzial seiner
Augmented Reality Brillen wir können
Sachen auf die Straße kleben an abige
Situationen kleben wir können da
Zusatzinformationen wie Schilder oder
Warnungen ausgeben in dem fahrenden
Fahrzeug wo das Fahrzeug sich bewegt im
Vergleich zur Welt unter Kopf und die
Brille und das git ein stabiles Bild das
gab's noch nie zu sehen das heute
allererste Mal dass überhaupt jemand
erleben wird neben seinem neuen CLA
Konzept präsentiert Mercedes auch einen
neuen virtuellen Assistenten KI basiert
wird mehr Interaktion zwischen Fahrer
und Auto möglich unter anderem
verbessern 3D Grafiken das
Fahrerlebnis dem neuen virtuellen
Assistent ist ein Dialog möglich mit dem
Fahrzeug ein völlig neues Erlebnis
zwischen Fahrer und Fahrzeug was völlig
revolutionär sein wird
bei all der Technologie Euphorie geraten
kritische Aspekte in den Hintergrund
dennoch setzen sich Entwickler natürlich
auch mit Fragen zum Datenschutz oder
Gefahren von KI
auseinander wer geht wie mit welchen
Daten um wer entwickelt Modelle was
machen diese Modelle das wissen wir eben
oft nicht deswegen muss man so ein
bisschen Skepsis davor haben Angst würde
ich sagen nicht weil wir haben natürlich
noch die Kontrolle über solche Systeme
wir müssen sie nur nutzen und müssen
entsprechend auch gucken was machen die
und wie wirkt unseren Alltag aus und das
ist halt entscheidend wie wir in Zukunft
mit KI einfach umgehen es liegt also in
unserer Hand und das wird hoffentlich
auch so
bleiben t be einem technischen
Fortschritt den die Menschheit so
vorantreibt manche Dinge bleiben
offenbar schwierig z.B Menschen zum Mond
zu fliegen Heinz ja die
usraumfahrtbehörde NASA hat die geplante
erneute Landung von Astronauten auf dem
Mond um ein Jahr auf 2026 verschoben sie
begründete dies damit dass mer Zeit für
die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen bei der
Mission emis 3 gebraucht werde
unterdessen hat das private
Raumfahrtunternehmen astrobotic
technology sein Vorhaben aufgegeben ein
unbemanntes Raumfahrzeug auf dem Mond zu
landen nach erfolgreichem Start
verhindert nun ein treibstoffleck dass
die Raumkapsel perigreen auf dem Mond
landet die deutsche fußballiga hat für
das kommende Bundesliga Wochenende zu
Ehren von Franz Beckenbauer eine
schweigemine bei allen Spielen
angekündigt der FC Bayern gab am Abend
bekannt dass es am 19 Januar eine große
Gedenkfeier geben werde in der
bayernarena auf der von heute an für
einige Tage jeweils in den Abendstunden
der Schriftzug danke Franz zu sehen ist
Beckenbauer war am Sonntag im Alter von
78 Jahren
verstorben ein großes Fußballstadion hat
ja tatsächlich etwas sakrales es sind
Kathedralen des Sports Fußballspieler
aus topliegen sind es gewohnt dass sie
an Spieltagen in diese Kulissen
einziehen umjubelt und gehuldigt von
ihren jeweiligen Gemeinden und das macht
natürlich auch im Fernsehen eine Menge
her wenn die Kameras über spielelder und
Zuschauertribünen fliegen bei anderen
balsportarten geht es ja wesentlich
bescheidener zu das liegt natürlich
nicht nur an geringeren Zuschauerzahlen
sondern hat auch einfach technische
Gründe Handball und Basketball Felder
sind nun mal kleiner und müssen außerdem
trocken sein doch bei der Eröffnung der
Handball EM am Mittwoch in Düsseldorf
wird es das XL Format geben in der
Düsseldorfer Fußballarena die dafür
extra umgebaut wurde Normen odental
zeigt
wie sieben Tage werden zu Sekunden harte
Arbeit sieht nach Vergnügen aus der
Zeitraffer verniedlicht den enormen
Aufwand aus dem Stadion in dem sonst die
Düsseldorfer fort Fußball spielt ist
eine handballarena geworden alles für
morgen einen Tag zwei Spiele Fabian
Müller managed den Umbau und weiß auch
ein kurzes Vergnügen braucht große
Logistik am Ende machen wir das für die
Menschen für gute Momente und je nachdem
wie lang der Moment ist ist der genau
richtig und wenn es zwei Handballspiele
sind ist do schön dass nicht nur eins
ist 53 000 Zuschauer sind dabei mehr als
je zuvor bei einem Handballspiel für
diesen Weltrekord wurde tonnenweise
Material verbaut Lampen Traversen
Zusatztribünen die näher ans kleinere
Handballfeld Rücken seit einer Woche
wuseln die Gewerke Koordination ist
alles das Dach der Arena ist zu
heitstrahler an aber wird's auch warm
wenn es draußen kalt ist das jetzt auch
nicht zu viel heizen auf we 28° geheizt
und dann kamen 50000 Menschen
Heizleistung hier rein und dann konst
auluss machen für Müller und Co
jedenfalls heißt es sowieso cool bleiben
aufgeregt sein bringt ja nicht viel ne
ähm ähm ich habe mal ein Leitsatz eines
eines sehr erfahrenen alten Kollegens
mitbekommen der sagte ähm äh um 18 Uhr
aus stors um 20 Uhr ist Show immer die
Frage ist nur wie laut wir uns bis dahin
anschreien dementsprechend ich schrei
nicht gerne dementsprechend ähm hilft
hilft da nur Gelassenheit und gute
Planung der Rasen ist herausgerissen der
Boden wird bereitet die
Unterkonstruktion stammt aus der Arena
in Köln und kommt dahin auch wieder
zurück Nachbarschaftshilfe unter
reinischen Rivalen geht doch schließlich
sind die Kosten eh schon immens der
deutsche Handballbund rechnet mit 2,5
Millionen Euro ist es das alles
wert wir sagen ja sonst hätten wir es
nicht gemacht wir sagen wir wollten
dieses Highlight setzen zu Beginn des
Turners wir wollten einfach auch eine
Highlight für für unseren Sport setzen
nur ist das noch Handball haut nah 80 m
oder mehr vom Oberrang bis zum Spielfeld
da ist jede seehilfe willkommen Brille
Fernglas ledwand springt der Funke so
über die Rahmenbedingungen sind
geschaffen damit die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft glänzen kann wie E
und je die spielerischen Leistungen
können wir nur sehr bedingt beeinflussen
mit dem was wir tun alle Regularien des
Verbandes sind eingehalten
dementsprechend besteht
Chancengleichheit für alle
und mit mit mit dem nötig mit dem
nütigen Willen wird die
deutstionalmannschaft das sicherlich
schaffen das Spiel zu gewinnen es wäre
wichtig für das Team für das Turnier für
die Idee vom Handball im XXL
Format das war's von uns gleich geht's
weiter mit der Reportagereihe 37° heute
unter dem Titel grenzenlose Liebe und um
0:30 Uhr gibt es dann unser heute
schonal Update mit nasan göckte mir und
uns morgen wieder in der
handballhalbzeit auf Wiedersehen
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
eigentlich
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ja
strahlenden Sonnenschein gab es heute
über weiten Teilen Deutschlands wie hier
im Harz und das haben wir unserem Kälte
hoch zu verdanken es verlagert seinen
Schwerpunkt jetzt etwas weiter nach
Norden das ändert für uns aber nichts
wir bleiben weiter in seinem
Einflussbereich das bedeutet auch es
gibt weiter trockenkalte Wintertage im
Südwesten allerdings kann es heute Nacht
zwischen Schwarzwald und den Boden Sie
doch mal leicht schneien auch im Norden
und Nordosten bleibt der Himmel durch
Nebel oft bedeckt sonst ist es aber
sternenklar das heißt es kühlt wieder
aus meist auf -5 bis -14° vor allem über
Schnee nur direkt am Wasser und auch am
oberrein ist es etwas weniger kalt
morgen bleibt es bei dem Dauerfrost -1
bis -4° nur an der See und auch in den
tiefen Lagen des Südens und des Westens
sind leichte Plusgrade möglich dazu
scheint erneut häufig die Sonne wie auch
heute aber der unangenehme eisige
Ostwind ist etwas schwächer das heißt
die Temperaturen erscheinen nicht mehr
ganz so viel kälter und es bedeutet aber
auch gleichzeitig dass sich die
Nebelfelder wieder dichter ausbreiten
oder wieder deutlicher ausbreiten und
das vor allem im Nordosten des Landes
auch im Südwesten halten sich einige
Nebelfelder länger und da wo das
geschieht erreichen wir morgen nur 0 bis
2 Stunden was die Sonnenschein betrifft
in einem breiten Streifen in der Mitte
sind es aber 6 bis 8 Stunden also das
maximal mögliche ist dabei auch am
Donnerstag gibt es in der mit und im
Süden noch einmal viel Sonne von Norden
her drücken dann aber immer mehr Wolken
ins Land und zum Wochenende hin wird es
etwas weniger kalt und damit auf
Wiedersehen